let's talk about MSNBC for a second
because I talk about all the time how
all of the networks just hire X White
House people there is a good julion
people MSNBC is doing a lot of it with
with David Axelrod and Michael Steele
they do it on both sides everybody does
CNN just hired Jay Carney which i think
is literally he worst thing in cable
news to hire the White House spokesman
the paid liar to the media to now be
part of the media not fair Jimmy's with
me on this one but MSNBC did have a new
hire this week they hired Weiss White
House associate communications director
her name is Rachel rakuten and she's
going to be MSNBC's VP of communications
and we've got a quote from MSNBC girl
you want that picture but will give you
the picture back after according to
MSNBC's press release during her White
House tenure rakuten played a key role
in devising press strategies for the
president's domestic events and major
policy announcements including the state
of the union address climate action plan
on the White House working families
summit the economic agenda and in
responding to the situation in Ferguson
and the Ebola crisis okay so by all
accounts she's a pretty decent lady I
don't mean this personal to her in any
way but I'm so sick of the people that
their media is supposed to be guarding
becoming part of the media Jimmy before
you punch me go oh you mean so you're
saying that it's just one big
capitalists gangbang that's happening in
our media right now there's nobody
really gives a [ __ ] about informing the
people it's just what we I can get from
myself and conventional wisdom gets spit
it out spit out over and over and over
nobody ever investigates tells the truth
all opinions are equal nobody's crazy
exactly like what Ben was saying
everything is equal everyone's opinion
matters just as much and we don't do
bump [ __ ] anymore we give it a
platform and then we repeat it ourselves
that's the new media that is what I was
saying and you said it a lot more
effectively then I don't have any
problem with this because she's this but
I mean this is gonna end with you to arm
wrestling that's how I but I don't give
a [ __ ] what
NBC msn / saul MSNBC doesn't really do
journalism like they're they're closer
and if you want to watch nine uh mostly
non crazy people talk as opposed to
pretty crazy people i would choose them
I guess but they're not breaking stories
right they don't have investigative
reporters right and so what they have
done is a reasonable decision of hiring
somebody who has had really high she's
gonna coordinate press coverage I oh I
could care less who MSNBC fires to
coordinate right generally a problem
with having an analyst I'm i do not
think this is an example of it so I
think generally there's a prop ok so
what a guy like David Axelrod comes on
MSNBC who was Obama's campaign manager
I'm pretty sure we know what he's going
to say michael steele he was the orange
the head of the artsy he's on there by
the way they all do this obviously newt
gingrich's on CNN and uh both sigh this
is actually i do it this is one of the
few times were both sides actually do it
um but sexy do it um but it doesn't
matter like those guys are brought in to
break stories they're literally brought
in to be talking heads so the issue is
because the sort of the discourse in
this country is framed by the cable
networks and what they're talking about
and having newt gingrich and michael
steele uh debate Jay Carney and David
Axelrod it doesn't move the ball down
well that's oh so I mean to that extent
I agree except none of those shows
though 24-hour news cycle all they do is
talk yeah they don't break any stories
where would matter I suppose and where
there might be an objection is if a guy
came from not working in media I don't
know Jay Carney's history was priors
reporter before well then it then then
he might be a bad example but if you
brings if David Axelrod came in and then
he became the editorial editor of The
Washington Post well then you you do
Republicans would certainly complain and
you might have in a sense that hey this
because this is a guy who couldn't be
more sort of mainstream Washington
that's who you don't want what that he's
on MSNBC is indifferent to me and Rachel
recursion was named one of the 50
hottest uh Washington workers yet now
you could put the picture back up
preferably promised Lee I mean I don't
bring it up she was already in a
magazine
as being a try officially declared
attractive and she's lovely yeah wow she
is lovely now Jimmy I know the
commenters and they're gonna say but you
guys hockessin you can make about a joke
i'm almost anything at this one um i
know the commenters they're gonna say
well you guys are just talking so what's
the difference between you guys and
MSNBC i know you have a good answer for
that the difference between us and MSNBC
is that we have integrity and that we
don't we don't have corporate overlords
telling us what to say genk has already
told story about story about how he he
one time he was doing a story that had a
sponsor's name it they made him take it
out so there's all we don't have that
here so we can that's why people come to
the internet is because i can say stuff
like i say and it's you're never gonna
get this on on corporate news media
you're gonna get both sides do it
everything's equal repeating talking we
debunk [ __ ] we don't repeat it
that's the big difference so the real
thing is what you were saying that
basically they bring on these people so
the argument basically is from like here
to here like republicans down here but
really the argument is a much bigger
thing but we never even get to those
ancillary parts right and TV news
doesn't advance stories they don't they
gave up on they used to there was a time
when they go up but they don't get it
it's just arguing you know look I've
said this a thousand times but it's
really one of my greatest points ever in
the history of cable news no one has
ever said not one time wow I didn't you
know Dave I never thought about it that
way like those words have never been
uttered yeah I see it on this show every
week such a good point I never thought
about that thanks okay like that what
kind of what kind of like to CNN would
just eight digit literally would never
happen all they do is they make their
point and then they they fake laugh
they're all friends yeah okay Jimmy
you're with your ratchet we'll be right
back after it's worth
you